[Music]
big art news at Sotheby's auction house
in New York artist Andy Warhol's double
Elvis sold for 37 million dollars
exactly now this means ladies and
gentlemen it's very exciting news for me
means I can make a ton of money selling
my prized pop art masterpiece I've owned
it for several years here it is in
person
my quadruple Buscemi
[Applause]
is invaluable now although it's not a
work by Andy Warhol it is the inspired
work of Newport beaches own atom war
hime he's very very good
I believe this work transcends monetary
value I will begin the bidding at a mere
seven million dollars will start at 7
ayah yeah I got five bucks on me sold to
Danny Richter for $5
congratulations Andy all right you're
the owner of a quadruple Persephone
awesome I'm just gonna give him
something difficult on in the crowd
that's fine
[Applause]
you know why tonight split it up into
fours
here for my painting all right I'm gonna
do uh that's beautiful hold it for me
sir we could have had a professional do
that thank you
no one's happy with your decision I like